Forbes Magazine estimates the Royal
Family's wealth overall to be 28 billion
the Queen's personal wealth that 442
million dollars is quite small in
comparison part of the problem with
estimating royal family as well is that
no one really knows the true value of
those prices gems and their art
collection and their palaces
here's what we do know about the Queen's
500 million dollar personal wealth
it includes England's 20 000 acre
Sandringham estate and her favorite
residence where she passed the 50 000
acre Balmoral Castle in Scotland Queen
Elizabeth inherited both properties from
her father King George VI it is presumed
she has passed them down to King Charles
who already had an estimated net worth
of 500 million dollars the Queen's rules
not being made public we may not ever
know what Charles's actual inheritance
is we do know the queen passed on the
duchy of Lancaster estate to her son
worth 950 million dollars
it is a massive sweep land and premium
real estate around the United Kingdom
King Charles in turn passed his
previously owned duchy of Cornwall
property portfolio to Prince William he
now owns 0.2 percent of England's land
worth around 1.2 billion dollars that is
in addition to his prior estimated net
worth of 40 million because William has
now inherited that dutchie estate it
means that he is now financially
independent so whereas he was supported
by his father in His official work he's
now got his own pot of gold to finance
his and his wife's official work Harry's
estimated worth was 60 million and while
he and Megan's departure indeed caused
the Royal riff it is unlikely they were
written out of the Queen's will knowing
how much the queen adored her
grandchildren and her
great-grandchildren I'm sure that
accommodations have been made for all of
them including Harry and Megan and
Archie and lillibet I'm sure pieces of
jewelry special mementos will absolutely
have been reserved for those great
grandchildren too but how the royal
family amassed 28 billion dollars has
come under scrutiny they've been accused
of inheriting Priceless stolen Treasures
through England's history of
colonization there has been cause for
reparations for slavery dating back to
colonialism they have also been caused
from South Africa from India to return
some of the Diamonds the rubies and the
stones gifted to the queen some of which
are set in Priceless pieces of of Royal
paraphernalia
foreign